how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe now i know i don't
normally post on sundays but it's
saturday night and we got some pretty
big news
now the past few days have been
absolutely insane for marvel and
star wars fans at disney's investor day
they revealed
a ton of new marvel projects both for
phase four and for phase five
so a lot of the talk recently has been
about these new projects but let's not
forget about one of the most exciting
things happening right now and that is
spider-man 3.
and today thanks to an exclusive report
from fandomwire.com we have some new
details about the film and about doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
both involving tobey maguire before we
dive into it be sure to subscribe to
stay up to date on mcu news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a
tony stark quantum suit funko pop i'm
picking a winner next friday
so as expected it appears that toby
maguire's role in spider-man 3 is not
just going to be for a quick
role his time in the mcu isn't just
going to be in spider-man 3 but he is in
fact going to go on to be in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
according to a new report from
fandomwire spider-man
toby maguire spider-man that is isn't
just going to pop up in spider-man 3 and
maybe make a quick cameo in doctor
strange too but he'll actually have an
important role in what's happening in
the mcu
now during the investor day kevin feige
the president of marvel studios did
confirm
that one division will connect to
spider-man 3 and spider-man 3 along with
one division will connect to doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
and we can already see how wanda is
going to be in doctor strange 2 and
doctor strange is going to be in
spider-man 3. and this new report from
fandomwire gives us a little bit more
information in their report they say
they can exclusively reveal that toby
maguire spider-man will have a role to
play in dodger strange in the multiverse
of madness toby maguire will of course
have a role in the third spider-man film
but his role doesn't stop there and they
issue a spoiler warning so i will issue
the same if you don't want to know
anything about it click away now
they go on to say both one division and
the third spider-man movie are going to
deal with the reality warping and
multiverse shenanigans
and of course this is already confirmed
but they say due to the fabric of
reality being disrupted in one division
it's gonna be in need of some fixing the
mcu's third spider-man flick will deal
with the fallout
however the problem won't be solved
until doctor strange two
and it'll be up to steven strange to
help out wanda but he won't be
alone according to fandom wire toby
maguire is going to be helping doctor
strange
now toby maguire spider-man is going to
be from another reality
and perhaps he can't get back to his own
reality until our main mcu timeline
and universe has been properly corrected
it seems like a lot of the universes are
going to somehow be colliding
it doesn't actually seem like doctor
strange is going to open portals to
these other universes but the problem
may actually be universes colliding into
each other for some reason whatever that
may be it may be the snap it may be
because of wanda
we don't know yet but we do know that
it's going to be up to doctor strange to
fix it and now
apparently toby maguire is going to be
sticking around after spider-man 3 and
is going to be helping doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness super
exciting news so let me know how excited
you are about this in the comments down
below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you stay up to date on all
the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
me